i'm in la that i felt completely normal
koreatown was possible
say it again say it again dude
they didn't give a [ __ ] it was the first
weekend everything was open dude i'm
talking
traffic parking impossible to find yeah
restaurants
dude we almost there almost there
we crawled through some [ __ ] like andy
dufresne we almost there
i like that we went to saint montana
dude i experienced my first little
racism oh you did yes
yeah i actually enjoyed it i went to the
bathroom
i walked by this korean table and the
they don't have their mask on and i see
the guy staring at me i was like i went
like this
i thought maybe he noticed me or
something and i go like this and he's
like
these friends why there's so many
[ __ ] white people
it was weird i was like wait did they
see steve and cat go to the bathroom
this would be fun
oh just a real white guy because i'm
kind of you know like is he
yeah stevie white as [ __ ] white blue
with a hot asian girl they must have
been like
[ __ ] that white that's what chin used to
be like
chin hated seeing white guys with asian
girls i didn't use me like that
i didn't hate it but it was yeah you
hate it i will say this
we gave them names too what would you
call victimization
when the white guy is always the white
guys always grab
the asian girls because they love white
dudes mostly
but everyone loves like because it
started with the war right victimization
basically is it a world war ii thing
what are we talking about it's the world
no
what do you think most here's the thing
it's like world war two i feel like
there's a lot of people who like
things that are different from what they
are so like
asian girls like white guys or black
guys just because that's different from
what you grew up with like
you probably liked something other than
white girls because you grew up with
white girls oh you dated was black girls
wasn't it
in the beginning or jade the hot is hot
you know what my type is smoking hot
yeah white
black asian with you filipino
africans what is your brother that david
brazilian
both of us for a long time yeah we love
it but like
asian guys who hate on asian girls for
dating
other races only say that because they
don't have game
there are asian guys who have game who
never hate on asian girls for dating
outside oh that's
that's like that's life that's life
injury it's like it's like with us
like like black women we mean us
we got white girlfriends like black
women will go hard on us
but like if if uh if a black girl is
with a white dude
they get a lot of praise praises
the white guy definitely does it no
let's see he doesn't know
you yeah i don't know i stand world star
hip-hop
dude dude the [ __ ] the shade
the shade they clown they clown on white
white dudes that are with black girls
they climb on the black girl the black
girl gets [ __ ]
i feel like no no they they climb on the
block oh you couldn't find a black king
like look
michael b jordan gets so much hate
because it's the word around town is he
date a lot of white women
right so there's like ah he fine but he
date white woman now he's with
my future girl uh laura harvey yeah now
there's like oh that's why i'm talking
about sis and i like get that bag sis
now uh let's see what black girls with a
white guy uh serena williams
serena williams or eve they say like get
that bag
hold on hold on but get that bag because
they're married to
billionaires both of them are
billionaires yeah but they probably so
it's like get that bad girl
white dudes one started [ __ ] reddit i
think oh the other one yeah one
and eve's guy's like a billionaire too
yeah he's a billionaire not maybe not
billiard but they're [ __ ] wealthy but
yeah he he
read a guy's super wealthy yeah but eve
was already wealthy before that
yeah but she would a billionaire now not
like him yeah not like she doesn't have
[ __ ] barbershop didn't blow her up
but she had her own tv show eve
yeah she had it on tv yeah no i get that
that was a long time ago fellas
residuals residuals i don't think
residuals now she's still not paid like
her man
nah nah that's where your bag comes from
yeah i got you she leveled up
did you feel any hate with steve because
stevie you know he's from boston he's a
boston white boy yeah
that's even he's even whiter than like
you know what that's white white white
white
he's like winter hill game white say it
twice white white do you get do you get
weird looks like
if you like you and stevie are in public
like you see some more
asians and they like steve and i went to
asian tables like you believe this [ __ ]
man
do this
this culture stealing [ __ ]
young and we i didn't grow up yet we're
just kind of like why are they like the
white guys and then when you get older
it is a game it is like how you're
talking
like also why does it matter a good
league like stephen a good looking dude
like good looking dudes good looking
dude
white black yeah you know don't matter
yeah like i've seen some fire ass
asian dudes that look good yeah africans
whatever it don't matter bts
good looking's good well those not i
wouldn't say good looking okay
those are very feminine dudes gotcha now
you said it was a few names you called
so victim my asian is one well no just
victimization but
it was more there had been like a racial
term though it was more for fun though
yeah kind of because we were like yeah
we couldn't get the girls oh man they
always they always pick the the hot
or good looking white guy so we're just
like joking around not actual hate
though
no do you do you feel weird do you like
you walking around with your girl or
anything like that i walk around like
the king i
am yeah you don't care yeah yeah but if
you go around the homies i bet there's
some
slang twitter oh she haven't been
do you take her to like prince charles
you don't take it
no we stay above the 10. stay above the
10. yeah
because you don't want to do what but
and you don't post her online so they
don't know well she's not online i took
uh
i took my girl to the uh that uh movie
theater
and chris shaw on the mighty johnson
hill
no really like gaming you don't have to
clutch your pearls like that
it was the cheapest one it was the
cheapest theater so we went we went
there but
you you don't feel like i don't either
because i'm like
like my family loves her all that stuff
so that that's all that matters to me
anyone else i don't give a [ __ ] you know
but y'all y'all homies yeah this
listen love is love now do you get weird
looks with your girls that's what i'm
saying
but i bet you get weird she doesn't you
do
like if you're at like a ritzy white
part like if you're an orange like
newport or something you go to
say you know some fancy uh let's say you
go to javier's out there do you get
weird looks
because she's with because you're not
like like skin black
he just said he was like
whenever i see a black guy with a white
girl i'm like yeah i mean he got a big
ass dick
that's just i assume i think they're
packing i think that's what a lot of
like white people think
whenever they see it yeah i sell a brand
like ooh i paid a big old dick
black white girl i like i don't know i
never really noticed because i'm not
like
i don't walk around like curious if
people were like
you know looking at me yeah that was the
first racism i've ever experienced
yeah i encourage them like yes more more
and more and more
happy black history month how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son